tokio 2020 llega a su fin y una
ceremonia de clausura en la que la
capital japonesa pasa el testigo a parís
la ciudad que acogerá las justas de
verano esto será en 2024 annie de algo
la alcaldesa de la capital francesa
presente en esta ceremonia recibe la
bandera olímpica de manos de yoriko creo
que la gobernadora de tokio pero antes
de todo eso a lo largo este día se
llevaron a cabo ya las últimas
competiciones empezando por el maratón
que ganó el keniano eliud kipchoge y la
grana favorito quien se impuso sin
problema en un tiempo de 2 horas 8
minutos y 38 segundos
latinoamérica consiguió dos preseas más
en boxeo gracias a beatriz ferreira que
se quedó con la plata tras perder su
combate ante harrington de irlanda
mientras que andy cruce cuelgo el oro en
la categoría de el peso ligero
las estadounidenses brillaron por
partida doble por una parte en voleibol
las estancias que vencieron a brasil 3
por 0 primera vez además que ganan un
oro olímpico en este deporte y por otra
parte también en básquetbol eeuu venció
a las japonesas 90
y cinco y séptimo oro consecutivo que
consigue eeuu en este deporte por su
parte las francesas en balonmano en esa
final que disputaron ante el equipo del
comité olímpico ruso se impusieron en un
excelente partido 30 25 victorias para
las francesas primer título olímpico
para ellas que logran lo que ya sus
colegas hicieron en la noche de ayer
tras vencer a dinamarca en la final de
balonmano